Ah! There you are, I was waiting for you to start touring La Grande Boutique!
Welcome to Roland Garros 2021!
We are at the bottom of the Philippe Chatrier court as you can see
this magnificent court was inaugurated last year,  and just by the Place des Mousquetaires
And to go to the Grande Boutique, we have to go down, follow me!
In Cannes, we go up the stairs, here we walk them down...
To land at one of my favorite spots: the poster’s wall.
It’s been going on for 40 years, it’s a tradition.
Every year, one artist is selected to design the Roland-Garros poster
Each one is more beautiful than the other.
My favorite is the Björn Borg one, I have it at home
and I’m quite proud of the one from my year of birth - 1990 -
the first poster with a woman on it!
Hello, welcome to Roland Garros, would you like a bag?
No it’s alright we’re here to take a tour, thank you so much.
Enjoy the visit!
Thank you!
we’ll start with the played tennis ball area, just by the entrance.
Hey,how are you?
You’re a tennis ball boy?
yes exactly
...
you’re tall for a tennis ball boy!
it’s the first time you’re doing this?
yes it’s my first time,
But what are you doing here, shouldn’t you be on the court?
I’m just coming back from it. I came to bring back the latest playedball.
The ball played… so all of those are balls played?
yes
and they are for sale?
yes, they are packed and displayed here.
that’s a great souvenir! I can see you have 2020, 2021…
Exactly.
thank you so much for your explanations!
You’re welcomed!
let’s move toward the Stringer area.
it’s right there!
One told me it moved this year so I’m a bit lost.
well it’s in the boutique wilson.
Ok
and the cordage area is just there
wow, it’s a nice area
yes
Magnificent…
What is it? You’d like me to bring it over for you?
yes if you don’t mind, please!
Sure, tell me what’s your tension
Hmm, 23-24 please
23-24, to pick up when?
tomorrow if it’s possible
Tomorrow morning?
Yes in the morning, that’s good
I’ll let them know you’ll come pick it up yourself
though, I won’t do that for you!
Yes that’s cool, no worries! Thanks
This is Roland-Garros's den, the backstage.
They are 20 stingers at all times, from 11 different countries.
Can someone take care of Harold Mayot’s racket please?
Yes of course! Thanks
It would be for tomorrow morning, 23-24!
And if you have a springer available to give me and my guest some details
Yes of course! There you go…
Are you available to talk to my guest here?
Yes of course! It’s 23-24 correct?
yes 23-24
So they are 2 types of cordage: the mains and the cross.
You are requesting 23 on the mains and 24 onthe cross.
The tension depends on few parameters, including the player’s racket,
its strings type, the temperature,the weather ect. Many parameters!
if it’s warm it goes up, if cold, it goes down.
Yes exactly!
23-24 is standard correct?
Yes! For men it’s a good average.
are women higher or lower?
A little higher.
little higher?
yes they play a little more flat.
yes it makes sense. Well, thanks a lot!
Bye!
Believe the record is 450 rackets strings in a day.
Which is huge! And on average, it takes 19 minutes
I don’t know if you’ve ever tried that but it’s quite a performance.
So here is the shop, with all those tennis balls hanging,
seriously I love that! It’s mesmerizing.
The shop is divided in 2 parts: the Roland-Garros brand just here,
and there the Lacoste and Roland-Garros collaboration.
So lets start with the Griffe Roland-Garros and my favorite area:
clothing for kids, so cute, I can look at those for hours.
Adeline,how are you?
Hello Alize, I’m good and you?
Good, what are you up to?
well it’s my daughter’s birthday in a few days
and she’s a tennis fan so I’m looking for an outfit.
I have a crush on the dress.
You’re right, it’s too cute.
and the skirt? What do you think?
I prefer the dress, but it’s cute too. I would have to visualize it with a top but…
the dress is too cute, you can’t go wrong with it.
I’m with you on this, I’ll take the dress.
Trust me, I’m sure it will suit her well.
Let’s do this then.
Okay I let you do your shopping.
thank you, bye!
Let’s check out the towels’ wall. It’s a tradition every year.
They are towels designed for the men and one for the women.
We exchange them to get the whole collection.
They are also the Night Sessions’ design and the one for the finale.
Over all it’s 4 towels designed each year.
And this one looks familiar… but it’s not from this year…
I overheard you… and this year indeed, we are offering a range of upcycled towels, made from last year’s towels!
Upcycled ? I know about recycling but not upcycling?
Yes we used the towels from last year to transform them into bags and pouches.
ok well this is smart, bravo! No waste then!
and it will be easier to maintain.
to wash yes!
and it’s a good step for the planet.
you are right, the environment. Bravo, excellent idea.
Thank you!
I let you go back to it!
Goodbye!
so then near the towels’ wall, we have the T-shirts’ wall. Just here.
Hi hello I’m sorry to bother you.
Is it possible to buy this single thing ?
Yes, for sure ! Wait, let me scan it for you. Yeah, that’s good !
It’s forty five please
Perfect, thank you…
Well look, there’s Fabrice. Fabrice?
Hey!
how are you? Hello!
you know Axel from Lacoste?
So here is the string area. For the first time, it is visible to the public,it’s quite awesome.
yes, I know him! What are you up to?
we were just talking about the 50 years collaboration with Roland-Garros.
This year, we will be celebrating 50 years.
the brand’s 50th anniversary?
50 years collaborating!
the brand is even older!
so the collaboration is a few months older than me.
It’s your 50th birthday?
for that we’ll have to wait another few months.
so you are just a bit younger than the collaboration between Lacoste and Roland-Garros?
Exactly.
and what are you up to mark the occasion?
Precisely, for the occasion we can customize polo shirts.
And Fabrice, I am proud to offer you, your polo shirt, 50 years.
If you can talk about the tension, spring, all of that...
Lucky you! An early birthday present! You’ll be able to wear it on your birthday.
Can I wear it now?
yes so you can start getting used to it!
exactly.
Isn’t it Rene Lacoste’s outline?
Yes the “Basque Bondissant"
So nice! Thank you so much!
The customisation area is just back there. There are a few tags you can…
add on a polo shirt?
Everyone can choose to make their own.
great idea!
perfect thank you!
you are spoiled.
okay I have to go. I will head to the village area with my guest, upstairs.
aren’t there sunglasses upstairs?
Let's move on with the shop. So I have some numbers for you:
yes i believe so.
I’ll head there with you then. I lost mine.
okay then
after you,
bye Axel!
by Axel, see you next time!
Please help me pick one
Have you seen the latest collection Roland-Garros Peformance?
Nice, eclectic and amazing colors
Fashion and sports!
Exactly!
Lacoste has been great in that respect: combining fashion and sports together
Is it around here Village corner... I think you're at the right place to find your next sunglasses.
OK
Nice, this is the place for glasses.
I would still take your advice: it's never easy to pick shades.
OK, I'll let you browse for a bit and I'll get back to you.
Deal!
Let's keep going on the visit!
Thanks Alize!
Here is the "village area" with famous brands such as JM Weston. O2Feel is a very cool electric bike...
I would love to try it by the way, Sisley too...
And this is the event corner: with photos, Celebrity meetups, virtual reality experiences:
something special every day so that there is always something to discover.
Hey Guy! How are you?
What a nice surprise Alize! Doing great!
What are you up to? Buying something special?
Exactly
What is it? Is it like sand?
Just a slice of magic: the soil of the Philippe Chatrier tennis court,
and anyone can get a piece of it here.
To make it even more unique!!
Exactly
OK, so one brings back sand from vacations at the beach and from Roland-Garros,
one would bring back with him the very magic soil of the tennis courts.
Indeed! So happy to see you and looking forward to welcoming our public,
with a nice attendance this year, this will be an unforgettable edition.
Attendance? Last year it had to be 1,000 because of sanitary restrictions, and this year.this will be 5,000 right?
Last year, only 1,000 individuals were allowed in the central tennis court with the ability to wander in other areas.
This year, this will 1,000 per main tennis court so this will be around 5,000 people during the first week
with upto 13,000 people during the 2nd week. For the finals, semi and quarter,
5,000 people on the central court.
Out of?
The central court has a 15,000 capacity usually.
About a third then.
Not so bad considering last year situation.
I thought that was less than that, 5,000 top at any moment.
No, that's better than this, and also with a shiny new stadium ;
and let me thank all our partners by the way: broadcasters,
the whole tennis family, which has allowed us to display this brand new stadium with a magnificent roof.
We will have night sessions too, and that's a first.
That will be very soon, andwe're just ready.
Are you ready yourself?
I'm born ready.
You must be so impatient, preparing for a year for this moment.
Yes but it's a great meeting and we are getting ready for it all year long.
So that’s it, we can’t wait to have you here, come see us!
But there’s always a lot of people in Roland-Garros,
everyone’s a fan. Even those whodon’t follow tennis are Roland-Garros fans.
well enjoy the tour then! See you Alize!
Mugs, key chains,notebooks, hats, bibs, posters…
Wait, let me help you!
Thank you, I have so many things!
of course! You know you can pay here directly at this terminal.
Then I can have everything delivered directly to you.
But I don’t live in Paris.
That’s not a problem. We deliver everywhere in France and abroad.
That’s great!
thank you so much!
So here is the check out area and this year we have 3 innovations:
You can ask for a mobile sales person, if you’re someone impatient, like me.
You can alsoorder from the app, starting at 80 euros purchases,
and then there is the Click&Collect
for the ones who don’t want to leave the court and miss a set,and can collect everything here.
But wait! I ordered a cap! Thank you!
There’s an area where you can customize caps
and towels so I had mine customized in clay color, very original for Roland-Garros!
That’s it! This is the end of our tour! We’re back at the Posters’ Wall!
I will go get my phone and take a selfie. This is so photogenic.
Thank you for following meon this visit! I hope you enjoyed it and that Roland-Garros 2021 will be magnificent!
See you soon!